okay so this is gonna be a little bit of
a survey and somewhat of a tutorial I
wanted to tell you a little about these
lifting theorems and then actually try
to give you most of the ideas and the
proof of this bpp lifting theorem with
Nita and Tom okay so everybody knows
that communication is like cityís and
randomized communication complexity so
just a you know I don't have preached
the converted communication complexity
we all love it
that's why - so lower bounds for
communication your old fast
okay so lower bounds I'm going to focus
on this third method obviously this idea
of hardness escalation or a way to use
function composition to go from a
decision tree or query complexity
measure to the corresponding
communication complexity measure so
that's what I'll talk about today and
the basic intuition behind this is that
if we just look at the functions that
are like the the typical you know
poster-child functions in communication
complexity they're all composed
functions so the Equality function you
know Alice and Bob Ellis gets x1 through
xn Bob y1 through yn and you want to
know if their strings are equal and this
is just a big or of so F the outer
function f is an is an or an inner
function G which I'll call a gadget is
just it's just a parity function on two
bits okay
and likewise at disjoint you Skype
handing inner product they're all sort
of this type composed functions and F
I'll always used to refer to the top
function and it'll have n wires feeding
into it and at the bottom you'll have
repeated copies of a gadget G applied to
disjoint inputs and we like the inputs
to G to be as small as possible
and one thing that's important is in the
communication problem for each copy of
the gadget the inputs to the gadget will
be partitioned into two pieces so Alice
gets half involves gets half okay and
what we want to do is in general come up
with a theorem that says that as long as
I get to pick the gadget so as long as
the gadget is sufficiently hard that we
can study the communication complexity
of the composed function by studying the
corresponding query complexity or
decision tree complexity of the base
function okay so for example here the
top level function is or and the
decision tree complexity of or is linear
you have to query all the bits feeding
into F which is linear and
correspondingly we'd like to show that
the communication complexity of set
disjointness which is the lifted version
of the or function where the inner
gadgets and that that has corresponding
complexity linear okay so the easy
direction is assuming the gadget is
small the easy direction is to show that
once you have a decision tree for F you
can just mimic that decision tree to
come up with a communication protocol
for the lifted function okay so you know
here's the dumb decision tree for or but
in general if you have a decision tree
for your outer function the two players
I was involved just follow this tree so
given that the first bit of F it's query
to z1 they'll run a little protocol to
compute G on the corresponding bits x1
and y1 and depending on the answer go
left or right and so on so the
communication complexity will be
whatever the the best protocol is for
one of these little gadgets times the
height of the tree so that's the easy
direction in the hard direction is to
show the other way around that from a
protocol for the compose function you
actually can extract a decision tree
okay and there's many flavors of this
this is the deterministic version but
you can modify both sides so you can
talk about randomized protocols and
randomized decision trees and etc etc
okay so there's been quite a lot of work
it's been an active area I'd say it
started with these top two papers by
sure stuff and Raleigh's McKenzie and
now there's lifting theorems and it
really have a wide variety of contexts
I'm not gonna say too much about them
all but once you have one it's really
good because you can prove upper and
lower bounds quite easily now so it's
good not just for getting lower bones
for getting separations between classes
because you know once you have the once
you have the lifting theorem let's say
you want to prove all you have to do is
prove you know study the query
complexity of some base function that
gives you whatever separation you want
and then just apply it and verbatim with
the lifting theorem and you
automatically get the same result in the
communication world so it's called
lifting because your or escalation
because you're kind of translating a
lower bound in a simple model to a lower
bound in a more complicated model or it
said the other way around
you're kind of showing that in the
communication world the only thing that
you can do is like the obvious protocol
and there's been lots of applications
mika will talk some about extending
these ideas to a dag version of
communication complexity I think that's
what he's going to talk about and how to
get monotone circuit lower bounds from
that some of them are new the Roberts
lifting theorem you can apply it to get
new results about linear secret sharing
scheme it's a really exciting work in
extended formulations where they use
lifting theorems in that context to
prove you know very strong exponential
lower bounds on deterministic and even
approximate algorithms for extended
formulations and so on and so forth so
there's lots of applications of this so
but I mostly just want to hone it get to
the you know get to the theorem and try
to give you an idea the proof so the
theorem roughly is that I'm gonna again
I'm going to pick the gadget and it's
the same gadget that's been used a lot
it's the gadget it's the original Rose
Mackenzie gadget and I want to show that
no matter what F is F
the outer function and I want to stress
that f it might not be a function it
might be a search problem or partially
or partial function and that's really
important in the applications so it's
really important that f is like pretty
much completely generic so I'll call it
a function but it really any
applications it's often like a search
problem okay so we want to show that the
randomized distance decision tree
complexity of f times the log n overhead
which is this is going to be required
for them to compute one copy of the
gadget that that's roughly equal to the
randomized communication complexity of
the lifting thing
so here's the gadget so it's called the
index or pointer gadget and this is a
picture of the gadget you know one copy
of the gadget so in general F is going
to have n inputs and the gadget is not
going to be constant like it was for and
or parity it's going to be bigger than
that in fact one side that it's going to
be asymmetric or uneven one player is
going to have order log in many bits and
the other player is going to have like n
to the third or into the I'm saying into
the hundred bit something like n to the
third bits so Alice gets a string of
length log m and bought a Bob gets a
string of length M and this is like this
is sort of like a universal gadget
because it can encode any function this
is like a truth table of a function and
this is like asking this is like an
index so it's asking what's the value of
this function on this on this input
they interrupt me a few it's good so
again you might think this is weird
because Bob's string is so big so when
we do this composition we have an outer
F and there's and we have to feed and so
F originally had variable Z 1 through Zn
now we replace each Zi by you know tons
of variables so order log n times into
the hundred which is a lot more very but
it's still polynomial and n okay but you
might think well this is a big problem
how are we going to get this but the
point is that you know in any lopsided
thing the trivial protocol is that the
person with the shortest string just
sends the string to the other player and
since this is order log N in length
that's where this is coming from okay so
even though one side is quite long it
doesn't really affect anything so that's
we measure it's like what's important is
the size of the shorter string okay so
just to tell you I think probably you
know but I'll tell you what a randomized
decision tree is so it's just you can
think of it as either distribution on
deterministic decision trees or as a
single tree that has coin flip nodes and
in query nodes so this is as a single
tree it has coin flip nodes and so you
go this way with probability P and 1
minus P and then you have query nodes
that query variables okay and for every
assignment to the z variables this gives
you a distribution on leaves of the tree
and the leaves are all labeled 0 or 1
and you say that the tree computes F if
for every Z you know the probability
that you get the right answer over the
distribution of the leaves induced by
particular value Z you know you get the
right answer to say probability 2/3 and
the height or the complexity is you're
just counting the query nodes so you
don't count these notes
okay so just remind you what we're
trying to do we're trying to do the hard
direction so we're trying to show that
from an arbitrary randomized
communication complexity protocol for
the lifted function we can extract a
randomized decision tree whose height is
not much different than the original
number of bits sent over here and we're
going to restrict attention to
determinist you'll see why this is not
really a restriction in a minute but
we're going to restrict attention to
deterministic protocols over here but
we're going to simulate them so well
that that a randomized protocol which is
just the you know a distribution over
deterministic protocols it'll work for
each one so so we'll end up with what we
want
okay so how are we gonna prove this and
this is hot when I say how we're gonna
face I mean like I want to give you a
constructive proof so actually like an
algorithm for given an arbitrary
protocol it actually gives you the the
randomized decision tree okay so first
of all we're just gonna since we don't
know anything about F to begin with we
can't really use anything about F so
we're just gonna ignore F altogether
okay instead of thinking of pi so pi is
a deterministic protocol for the
composed function but we're really going
to think of it in terms of how it
partitions the inputs to F enjoy the
picture here hopefully this'll maybe
hope if not please interrupt me if this
doesn't make sense so this is a capital
X is all possible inputs to Alice okay
so she has n Times log M bits okay so
it's 2 to that and why is all possible
inputs 2 to Bob and his is like M times
n many bits okay and so I'm going to
think about so each of these points each
of these points in here okay
it's labeled with a so we apply the you
know each each gadget to it and that
gives us a vector of length of length n
so we'll call that as e vector so it
gives us when we apply this this should
not be -1 so this is like this should be
GG to the N of X Y so we apply you know
X is broken up into n pieces so is Y and
we apply G to each copy that gives us a
and bit string Z okay so we're just
going to think about so these colors
correspond to this is all the inputs all
the pair's XY where the corresponding Z
string is the same some particular value
purple okay and this is another one and
so on okay it might not look like slices
but it's just the sort of show you that
they're all kind of hopefully
distributed really nicely
okay so we're gonna think of this whole
space is partitioned into these Z slices
okay and we're really going to think of
the whole protocol with respect to what
it does how it deals with these e slices
okay okay so this is a picture of the
protocol it's that remember it's a
deterministic protocol so you know that
in this case this blue line means Alice
spoke first partitioned her and put into
two pieces and then Bob spoke and so on
so these are all the rectangles that
were induced by the deterministic
protocol pie okay and again I don't care
about the value of F on them but I
really care about is how each each Z
slice is distributed relative to them so
this is a particular Z slice so these
are all the inputs XY consistent with a
particular vector of length n okay and
when you run so imagine and so imagine
that for a particular value of Z like
the all-0 string imagine that you're
going to run the protocol PI over all
uniformly you're going to run it over
all the XY pairs in this in this slice I
think of that as being a uniform
distribution over them all so that's
going to give you a distribution over
the transcripts of the protocol right so
so this transcript in particular it's
like I don't know maybe like a quarter
of the time you end up in here okay so
this transcript will have probability
like a quarter with respect to the Z
slice and so on that makes sense
sorry supersuit you're thinking in an
item's point on the slice and looking
what's the transcript correct Nick and
that gives me a distribution so for
every Z I get a different distribution
of transcripts and for you know for the
purple one wherever it was you know that
would be over I would run the protocol
over the distribution of purple ones and
what I'm going to try to do is come up
with a randomized decision tree that's
instead of labeling the leaves with the
value of F composed with G I'll just
label the leaves with the name of the
transcript okay and what I'm going to
want is that for every Z that the
distribution of transcripts induced by
running this protocol PI on the pink
slice is going to be the same or roughly
the same as the distribution of
transcripts induced by running the
randomized decision tree on that same Z
value
Ismene a mouthful but that's
we're gonna make a randomized decision
tree the leaves of the decision tree are
going to be labeled with transcripts
from the from PI the communication
protocol and remember it's a randomized
decision tree so for every Z value and
it's a decision tree that queries
disease okay it only queries the inputs
to F and for every Z value therefore you
get a distribution on leaves which is a
distribution on transcripts now we want
that to be basically that's what I'm
calling this this is the decision tree
running on Z gives us a distribution
over transcripts and I want that to be
roughly the same for every Z as the
distribution of transcripts that would
be induced by you know running the
original protocol on a random XY you
know with corresponding value Z that
makes sense that makes sense for a good
a good portion of the way it doesn't
make sense so being boolean is not
relevant here you can just have the
values you mean for F yes correct yeah F
is usually any applications that won't
people in it doesn't even enter in
any questions yeah so I want it to be
like I don't know something like 1 in
polynomial in n for every Z 1 over N to
the third me
yes
okay so what can we possibly do so here
you are imagine now you are the person
you have the protocol in front of you
you know exactly how XY was partitioned
you know you know you you have this pick
you know this picture right this picture
but you don't know you have a Z value
but you haven't you know you can't only
look at bits when you query them so you
don't know anything about which slice
you're in initially and we're trying to
you know step by step look at the
protocol so the communication protocol
the first thing it does is per Alice
spoke first partitions this into two
pieces
step by step for trying to mimic this
with a randomized decision tree that's
only allowed to query the bits of Z and
we don't want to query the bits of C we
want to query them proportionally to the
length of the protocol on the left so
there's no really not whole lot that you
can do in the beginning so I was in
Whitman we want the distributional
transcripts to kind of be identical okay
so what can you do when when you know
that the first thing happens is this and
you don't know anything about the pink
well it seems to me the only thing you
can do if you know unless you know
something about F or whatever is that
you can go to this side proportional to
the size of the size of this sub
rectangle and this proportional to the
size of the sub or integral and if
you're really lucky the distribution of
X was in here the marginal on the x side
will be really close to uniform and
again the marginal of the pink thing on
the Y's will be close to uniform and if
that happens then when you go left and
right with probability proportional to
you know to the protocol that'll that'll
preserve the probabilities so that's the
whole idea we're going to always go left
and right with probability proportional
to the to the sizes what we know and and
when but we're going to have to keep
track of some measure that's going to
make sure that that this is going to
happen that our distribution marginal
distribution within the pink for every
pink slice is kind of roughly uniform
over the current
Oh exes in the current rectangle wise
idea I'm not clearing yet yeah yeah so
I'm gonna do this keeping track of some
measure of how much information I've
learned about each coordinate and when
too much information has been learned
about some coordinates at that point so
now I have to tell you how to do that
yeah here's usual way ahead in the habit
so like the very highest level will
simulate the protocol like I said going
left and right just proportional to the
size of the two pieces that were that
were broken up by the communication
protocol hopefully that we're hoping
that works but we're also going to keep
track of like I said is how much
information is revealed about the the
coordinates and when too much has been
revealed about a coordinate at that
point well you know query the
corresponding Z bit fix things up and
then go restore our invariance and go on
okay so this is the invariance this is
are the same the density is the same
thing same invariant from the earlier
paper by Mikah and others that got a
hunt to lifting theorem so again X is
always a subset of the set of all
possible X's and Y's a subset of all
possible Y strings so we have we're in a
rectangle X Y and the X part is said to
be dense if the main entropy so for
every capital I is a subset of the end
coordinates ok so remember we always do
X is consisting of block and blocks so
I'll call each block like a coordinate
ok you know what we need for density is
that for every subset of the coordinates
when you look at the distribution
induced on those coordinates by X the
min entropy of that is you know pretty
big like the most stickers
the most it could be would be the size
of I log M so that's how many bits there
are altogether and we want it to be like
a good fraction of it so some like
constant amount of bits have been
revealed possibly about I but not not
more than a constant fraction
mm-hmm and we want this for every I mean
large is just so just to say upfront
like why is such an enormous ly long
string that it kind of sits along for
the ride pretty much everywhere so we
don't really worry about it much so this
this condition is more or less saying so
this is the mint entropy the the total
number of bits minus the min entropy is
is at most n to the third so in other
words like on average like only enter
the third bits have been revealed but
but Y is enormous like each coordinate
of Y is n to the hundred lon so this is
like this is nothing
so this is these are the invariants we
want to maintain and as long as these
are maintained we'll do what I said as
soon as this invariants been you know
not met then we'll have to take an
action ok so this just is a little less
high level but still very high level
overview of the simulation simulate it
going left and right as long as X is
dense and Y is large
whenever density is violated and I have
to show you what we do and whenever
largeness is I layer well we just kind
of Hulton ignore it because it almost
never happens ok so this is the main
step to figure out when density of X is
violated how we're gonna fix those
coordinates and queer correspondingly
query those coordinates in in the
decision tree and then that will restore
our invariant on the remaining
coordinates so there's two things we'll
need to show after I show you how we're
gonna you know do this this restoration
but there's two things we'll have to
show you and just so I'm not gonna say
anything much about the you know one
thing we have to show you is the
complexity the decision tree we end up
with that the height of it's
proportional to the height of the
communication protocol I'm not going to
say too much about it but basically we
don't do this restoration until enough
bits have been revealed about the
corresponding coordinates so the so the
fact that we already communicated a lot
of bits in the protocol well you know
it'll make it okay to do the density
restoration okay so that's some kind of
a potential argument but basically
you're not going to query something
until a lot of bits have been revealed
and then this will be the hard part
showing that the distribution on
transcripts is going to be close
so this is how you do density
restoration so again like I said we're
ignoring what happens if why doesn't it
isn't large enough it's the only thing
I'm going to worry about is if X loses
density so if X loses density there's
some maximal subset of coordinates call
it I I one that where density hasn't
been maintained so this means that
there's at least one value for all those
coordinates that's too likely probably
lots of values bigger ok so let's say
alpha 1 is the actual value of all the
coordinates so we're fixing all the
coordinates in I 1 to some particular
value it's too likely okay and the X 1
is the subset of X where I one has been
set to alpha 1 okay once you do that
once you part it once you pull out X 1 X
1 will now be dense because we took the
maximal subset that wasn't dense people
are quiet
I don't know if I'm going to faster yes
question Conseco because basically the
protocol varies then at some point the
some input of very significantly fixed
point then when I call it that's right
exactly
it might not be one it might be a whole
bunch of the first 523 bits has been
fixed as opposed to
that's why sometimes you might that
that's why sometimes I one might be
enormous I might not be just one at a
time because you might have you might be
computing parodies of like 10
coordinates all at the same time like
Russell said and so after so you might
go for a long time and that all of a
sudden at the same time a whole block of
coordinates too much is known about them
any other questions yes I'll get to that
is I should have you up here here so
anyways you should think of this as
maybe I I mean it wasn't obvious to me
before me I said let's do this but now I
think that this is like you know sort of
obvious but again I didn't think of it
but I mean basically you need to restore
density so when density is violated
there's some set take it myzel take it
to be the maximum
myzel set it this is perfectly dense
then you have the rest of the stuff okay
so X minus x1 you move over here you
check again has done still even violated
if so you have another possibly
different set of coordinates I to that
where density has been violated fix it
to some to likely value but that breaks
off another part x2 and you just keep
doing this until until you've nothing
left
so so I'm I am partitioning X into
disjoint pieces each of which is now
going to be dense when you see your does
that mean you're like in the simulation
you're flipping a coin yes yeah you
you're ahead of me that's what we're
gonna do yeah so I will describe the
full simulation but to do that I have to
first tell you how we're how we're gonna
restore density in these sets i1 i2 i3
they may overlap yeah oh yeah yeah I too
could be the same set of coordinates as
i1 or differences yes yeah I mean just
by construction because we took some
stuff out we moved everything else over
took some more stuff home so when you do
this you start with X it's you know I
mean we're always gonna do this after
every step of Alice we're always gonna
check is X you know you know remember
when Alice makes a sense a bit it
partitions the current X into two pieces
will go to each side proportional to the
size and then we check on both sides was
density violated if so we go into this
process okay so you can view this as
like a is like a refinement of the
original protocol pie so I'm adding more
communication to it so before whenever
Ellis spoke she just sent a bit now when
she speaks she sends a bit and say left
and right is 0 and 1 and now she's gonna
send she's going to check to see if her
densities violated if so do the
partition and then said send the
coordinate I of you know she X has been
the current X has been partitioned into
X 1 X 2 and so on that partitions X and
she's gonna send the curse corresponding
bit I does that make sense this is like
a park tip so in this case say X does
isn't dense so Alice has to break it up
into a bunch of pieces x1 up through x4
so just think of that as like refining
the protocol so we're breaking X up more
now once that happens at that point
we want to Bob to speak so we want him
to now
partition his inputs into two pieces
based on whether not two pieces to to
the size of so let's say an X one let's
say X one just fixed say one coordinate
okay then at this point we want Bob to
partition his inputs into two pieces
those pieces were G so remember
excellent fixes that coordinate so now
Bob is going to apply G you know to his
input on this fixed value for that
coordinate and that's going to partition
Y up into two pieces where G is zero and
where G is one and if X one fixes like
ten coordinates then then Bob's gonna
have to send you know ten bits I'm still
just describing I'm just describing this
restoration process that's really just
you should think of it as a is a process
of refining the original communication
protocol this might this might be a look
look ugly but I'm gonna show it to you
anyways so this is the original protocol
okay
nothing nothing's going on here this is
just you know either Bob sends the next
bit B and then we update you know the
rectangles or Ellis sends a bit be okay
and then you update the rectangles
that's the typical original protocol and
now like I said I'm refining we're
refining this so that now when Ellis
ends a bit be that partitions X into two
pieces and now we're going to check for
each of those pieces whether density was
violated if so she's going to send more
information she's going to partition her
current X up into all the different
pieces and say which one the current X
is in okay so she sends this bit I and
then Bob is going to send a
corresponding message s that's going to
partition the Y up into all the possible
values that G could have on the fixed
stuff that was set
in X I
was isoline yes sorry about this bad
notation I have a better picture maybe
I'll get back to another picture of it
so again you think I'm just thinking
this is refine it put a quart it could
add a lot of length to the protocol has
a lot more bits could be sent and I told
you before I'm not going to worry about
that for now okay so I just want to show
it's not gonna be a big deal because if
there's these bits are only going to be
this extra stuff's only gonna be sent
when a lot of stuff has already been
learned about these coordinates but what
I want to do is show you what what the
full randomized decision tree simulation
okay okay I don't mean it's needed to
prove the theorem but it's needed in the
proof because we don't forget when we
when a coordinate has been too much
about its learned we have to fix it to a
value yet we've got at that point we're
going to query the decision tree just
like your manual said so we want to
query the corresponding coordinate and
we want to go left if it's 0 and 1 if
it's 1 so we have to at that point fix
you know partition the X and the y up
you know in two pieces so that whenever
you queried left and it was at that
coordinate the G value is zero that all
the XY are consistent with that and
likewise same thing that you do the
whole reason for maintaining the
invariant I think the whole reason for
maintaining the invariant is because we
want when too much information is
learned at that point we want to really
fix break up the X Y so that it's now
consists of a bunch of rectangles each
of which on that coordinate or fixed to
be 0 or 1 each of those rectangles
should be monochromatic on the fixed
stuff that was ok so here is the
simulation of this extended protocol on
a Z it's just what we said whenever Bob
sends a bit that breaks up Y into two
pieces and we go to each side in the
decision tree with the with the
appropriate probability with the same
probabilities hoping that the marginals
are
same okay and likewise when Alice sends
a bit we go proportional and again here
now Alice if she ever has to refine her
ex and partition it then again we're
going to go to in the decision tree we
have to decide what to do so we're going
to again randomly go to the piece the
piece I've with probability proportional
to the size of the of the piece in the
partition
and then here let me just finish it off
here when Bob sends s at that point this
is where we're going to actually query
the corresponding bits corresponding
coordinates the zi values in the
decision tree okay and for a particular
Z this is going to where this is going
to be a deterministic step Z has a
particular value so we'll go left or
right depending on this is Z is like the
input to F okay and here I'm going to
query so over here when X was broken up
into pieces there was some coordinates
that were to likely say coordinate 1 and
2 so then I'm going to fix this whole
this whole process here and think the
whole point of it is to is to break up x
and y further so that each piece is
fixed to be you know the coordinate one
two together are fixed so there's the
zero zero one zero one one zero one one
those are the two coordinates that were
clearing over here
so the the top three purple things
they're just a quaint
you know the dice rolls basically
everything is just everything is
literally just so you take it like
implementation wise you take the
original protocol pie you turn it into
this protocol which is easy to do just
refine it okay after you do that then
literally the simulation is just to
always go proportional to the size and
whenever you whenever
except for this step when Bob finally
sends this bit then that's when you
query the corresponding coordinates and
go according to your Z
[Music]
so can't just think of candy for this
results in it that any protocol can be
written it in a certain way that that
anything issue any communication program
can be refined a certain sense whether
it should tango learn our Center
structure meaning that image and direct
angle some coordinates antics and some
and then the rest of it so I didn't say
this but when you fix some stuff then
the whole argument when the whole
measure of dense and large is always
with respect to the aren't fixed ones
any protocol can be requires that every
rectangle has some called it fixed its
other son not sure so so we're
simulating the the protocol on the left
and we're always maintaining that every
rectangle the X part is dents on the
unfixed point at the y part is large and
and because of that because if that
property is maintained it'll turn out
that the that when you go when you no
matter what Z is when you go perp or
I'll show you this in a second but when
you go proportional to the size of how
the split is it'll always it'll preserve
rough it'll up to there up to a 1
inverse polynomial in N it'll preserve
the it'll be correct to within that
probability
I don't know if this doesn't say much
this is just saying the whole job is to
show that this distribution over
transcripts that I talked about in the
beginning so for every Z every vector of
length n you have two distributions on
transcripts one is the one where you ran
the protocol PI or PI bar over a uniform
element X Y that you know where the
gadgets on X Y get easy and the other
one is when you run the decision tree on
Z itself okay we're trying to show that
those two are really close to each other
and this lemma is just saying well we
can do this you know
node by node or step by step of the
protocol so we're going to look at like
when Alice sends a bit followed by
density restoration followed by Bob
sending his bits for if anything had to
be fixed that's going to be considered
like one step or one phase now we're
going to show that for every phase that
the distribution of the two message is
sent in that phase are close to each
other and then we'll stack them you know
stack them all up using a coupling
argument to show that the whole thing
that implies that the whole distribution
that the difference between the
transcripts on the whole distribution is
maintained
we just want to have to show message by
message or round by round that if things
start off well in this round Alice sends
one bit followed by one density
restoration step followed by Bob
sending his bits that that the little
distribution on messages on that little
round are going to be close to each
other exactly so that's what I wanted to
tell you I'll get to that in a second so
the the main like lemma that's gonna
make everything let everything go
through in addition to the fact that why
it's so huge is this uniform marginals
lemma that's saying as long as our
invariant is true so we're currently in
a rectangle XY and as long as X is dense
and Y is large then you know then we get
what we want for every Z value this is a
you know if you looked at the
distribution in the Z slice that
intersects X Y the marginal on X that's
going to be close to uniform on X and
likewise for y remember I said that
we're going to have a variant and if it
meant meant invariant is maintained then
we'll be able to you know then when we
go proportional to the sizes it'll be
good so this is exactly what's the
dilemma that's going to give us that and
I'll postpone this for a minute
so again the height just just two things
about lemma six which is uh so again
we're going to fix the Z and we're
fixing V which is a vertex and the
protocol so it's like once one place in
the protocol where Alice is about to
send a bit and we're currently at some
rectangle X cross Y is there's not the
whole thing but it's some sub rectangle
that I'm gonna call X across Y again
it's some sub rectangle and I'm just
gonna for now assume that everything's
perfect so far so I'm not going to worry
about mistakes that have happened
already
so that let's let's say so far that the
distribution so the XY distribution over
current rectangle is pretty close to the
X part is pretty close to the
distribution X Prime and y Prime
you know the that's induced by the XY
z-- in the Z slice so another is the
transcript so far the message is sent
and so far leading to this vertex I'm
assuming they're like nothing Bad's
happened so far this is saying that
everything's perfect okay so I just
wanted to give you one I'd just the two
ideas for why everything's going to be
good in this next round so this is a
this is just a picture of one of one you
know communication step where Alice
speaks so we're at some vertex V in the
middle of the communication protocol
there we find one so V is some vertex
and the refine protocol Alice speaks she
sends a bit zero or one okay that
partitions X into two pieces and now she
possibly has to do density restoration
so that was the original X cross Y and
when she sent the bit B one you know
maybe this is B equals one half okay and
then when she does density restoration
that partitions this into pieces right
each of those is now dense and then she
sends the name I of one of these pieces
say this one okay and then Bob sends his
bits and if if this density restoration
only so let's say all it did was work on
one coordinate so this so that would
give you a partition of Y into two
pieces where that all the inputs were
that coordinate was zero and where that
coordinate is one more generally this
could be partitioned into you know two
to the s pieces depending on how big you
know how big I is so anyways after this
this step L is sending a bit and then
sending the partition and then Bob
further refining the Y's we finally end
up with you know all of these little
like you know this whole space has been
partitioned into these pieces okay this
is no monochromatic with respect to the
fixed coordinates okay so all the fixed
coordinates are set the values of them
are set and have value s and everything
is done and this is dense
so basically by the uniform marginals
lemma you know when you're at this point
everything these two are going to be
close to one another because remember
what we did was we went here with
probability proportional to the size you
know we went we went to this side for
probably proportional in size and then
here with probability proportional to
the size okay and when we did that this
was dense in X so we can apply the
uniform marginal as I'm assuming that Y
is fine which I assumed it wasn't in the
beginning so since we applied it at this
point that to the new part of the of a
so the messages the two different
messages are going to be very close to
one another okay so then we just have to
so what what's bad that could happen so
with bad that could happen is if what
the y part here so we're going to query
you remember at this point after this
phase we're actually going to in the
decision tree we're going to query these
coordinates you know it could be that
for some value of those coordinates
there are no strings
you know the rectangle is empty here and
that would be bad that would lead to
error okay but what he said was that you
know basically this entire tree okay
just look at the whole possible tree and
how many leaves that could have okay and
X is so small compared to Y that the
total number of leaves it could really
possibly have is like exponential and
something like n log N and that's really
tight so the number of bits revealed by
this whole thing is like m n log n but
since we chose m to be like n to the
hundred that that's really a small
number of bits that are you know
revealed about why on average
so we're heavily taking advantage of the
fact that why is so big compared to X to
get that at every step though the chunk
of Y that's left over in each of these
pieces is significant in size and then
we're using the uniform marginal is
lemma to argue that you know that that
the two messages are going to be about
the same I thought this would be easier
to do in an hour so okay so I just want
to say a couple things about this
uniform mark don't give any questions
should I summarize we're at gray so I
described the protocol so you start with
the original CC protocol refine it I
described this process of making the
decision tree that's randomized and you
know and it was a little bit you know
refining the protocol was the
complicated part once we did that the
decision tree that corresponds to is
easy you just always go every with
probability with the right with the same
proportion and except in that one step
where you finally fix those coordinates
and in that case you make the queries
okay and what we have to show what's
left to show is this uniform marginals
lemma that as long as we maintain that X
is dense and Y is large then you know
we'll have this property that we want
that the marginals with respect to the Z
slice are going to be roughly the same
as the uniform distribution
so it's the same thing you know by
looking at it by using Fourier analysis
it's the same thing is showing this
property that so we're assuming X is
dense and Y is large and we want to show
that for every subset of the coordinates
I that the expected value when you you
know when you look at the distribution
on x and y with respect to that subset I
so we're picking a random x and y from
this distribution just looking at the
coordinates I that the expected value of
the product of the G is this is just so
think about G is being in 1 minus 1 for
now okay and this is like looking at you
know the number of times it's basically
the parity of it whether it's you know
it's 1 times minus 1 so it's like the
parity of of G on on all the places in Y
so remember what this is this is like
the index gadget so X points to a
location and Y and we're doing this for
all I and I and that's giving us a bunch
of values and 1 minus 1 and we want to
know what's the expected value and we
like this expected value we'd like this
to be you know very close to 0 ok so
that there's no bias toward 0 or 1 the
parity is roughly half the time 0 and
half a time line y just has to be large
so the large meaning like you know think
of it as like oh you know of the 2 to
the MN possible size it could be the
size of it is like T to the MN minus
enter into the third almost full size
yeah just think of it as you
so I'm gonna just try to say one word
about that not our proof but proof that
Ryan came up with I think it was
independently just realized by lots of
people okay so there's this lemma and
Ryan's book it's called level K
inequality lemma and it states that if
you have a boolean function f from
capital and bits to 0 one where the
expected value is alpha okay so that
means like the fraction of one's is
alpha and K is you know upper bounded by
some quantity then you can upper bound
the sum of the Fourier coefficients
squared of for all characters s of size
at most K so it's like all the bottom
Fourier coefficients the sum of all
those squared is gonna be upper bounded
by this quantity
it depends on depends on Alpha
I just want to show you how once you
have this lemma how kind of the uniform
marginals lemma fall is pretty
immediately from this
so this is this isn't saying much so
again I it's just some I'm just really
going to focus on the part of X you know
X has n coordinates and you can think of
if you want is n but it's just some
subset of the coordinates and it's and
we're dense which means for every subset
I were dense so I'm just going to focus
on one subset I of the coordinates and
what this is what we're trying to show
we're trying to show that that this
quantity so this is the expected value
so now I switch notation and x and y is
just the distribution over the the set
of coordinates and I so again you could
think of I is n so X is you know the in
that case X would be would pick all you
know an arbitrary s from X and arbitrary
Y from Y and here we're looking at this
is the value of the gadget so you know
on each of those places pointed to what
here well this is I mean this does end
up being being the value so Y sub I is
like the value so s is this I think of s
is a subset you know so for each for
each of the blocks you pick one place so
that's like a subset of size I and then
Y sub I would be the value of a gadget
on each of those places yes this is the
Z value yes so I'm looking at the parity
of the Z value yeah and I want to say
that the payer expected parity of the Z
value is you know it's half the time
zero and half a time one
so maybe it's better to look at it as a
matrix so here's the matrix version of
the picture on the top here are all the
Y's in my rectangle and on this on the
rows are all the X's and I'm labeling an
entry here
so in entry M sub s why so that's just
going to be I'm going to multiply you
know I'm over 1 minus 1 so I'm just
gonna look at so Y is a vector maybe
this helps so here's like a vector Y a
vector Y of length if I is n it's all of
them this is a vector of length m and
this is this is a particular Y it's
broken up into these and pieces and s is
s is a particular element in X so it's
picking out one place in each of these
okay and the entry and this vectors
labeled labeled -1 1 oh sorry minus 1 1
and so you know X picks out one location
in each of these blocks and I'm just
multiplying them together or I'm just
taking I'm adding them up mod 2 okay and
that's they're going to be the value of
M of s y
I'm just basically you know it's gonna
be you know and either one or minus one
and what I want so each of these entries
in this is going to be 1 or minus 1
depending on whether the parity of that
was 0 or 1
you know otter even and what I want is I
want this whole matrix when I take the
sum of all these 1 minus 1 interest to
be really close to 0 okay so you can
think of you can think of the
corresponding so I want to apply that
lemma so you can think of the correspond
a corresponding function which is that Y
is the ones of the function okay so you
have a function f and the ones of the
function are all the stuff in Y okay and
since Y is large you know the expected
alpha is is that okay and a row of this
matrix is more or less going to
correspond to the weighted Fourier
coefficient of that function with the
character s so s remember I'm viewing s
s is a collection of eye pointers so I
can view that as a subset of MN of size
n so it's a it's a size and this its
size I in this case isin size n
character so it's a subset of the
coordinates and so all this row is it is
this is basically the the Fourier
coefficient of F corresponding to to
this subset okay but waited waited
according to alpha
since yes once you have that it's really
quite easy to apply the lemma because
you know because because each of the
things in X it's a its weight is at most
the size of I which I was calling K so
its weight is bounded so you can just
directly apply the only thing that's
different is that the dilemma had these
things squared and we have absolute
value so you have to use post Schwartz
to get it in the squared for him I'll
skip this but basically you know like I
said you first apply the claim
you know the each row more or less
corresponds to the weighted Fourier
coefficient and then you just have to
apply koshi Schwartz to get it in the
form coefficient squared and X has some
of these characters of weight K but we
might as well just stick them all in
there or whatever inside and so then
Ryan's lemma or the dilemma the weight K
lemma tells you that this is upper
bounded by this quantity and then you
use the largeness of Y which is
corresponds to this alpha and the
density of X that's right the only thing
is like you just have to make them the
only thing that's the only reason you
don't get it immediately from like
extractor is because you have many
copies of it so I think another way you
could probably do it is by well the way
that yeah by reduction to extractor she
said there's yeah this is like a sleek
proof but the basic intuition is exactly
said it's also the same thing that's in
some sense in the earlier proofs to use
draws Mackenzie in some sense that's
very similar the basic intuition at the
end
so there's lots of open questions as I
would be interested to know if there
would be a lifting theorem for
information complexity be great to proof
to make some progress on a constant size
gadget herd to me in this last two weeks
that it would be variant I mean of
course the big open problem is to get
these methods to work we're starting to
make progress on getting to work for the
dog light case but really the huge
problems you know what happens when it's
not monotone so we'd like to kind of
these lifting theorems when you apply
them to circuit lower bounds you always
end up with a monotone circuit lower
bound and and Robert sort of explained
why but I don't know yeah it seems like
it should be possible to get this to
work in some setting in the non
monotonic ease and it seems quite
related to to some of the earlier work
on on the K or W conjecture that uses
it's related to the proofs and and
actually there's implications that
relate it to to the proofs of the
simplification of the KRW conjecture for
these universal relations so somehow I
feel like there should be some more
connections between the care W
conjecture and what's going on here
about it
[Applause]
so how would lift things are for
informational complex they look like do
you have any um so I think it should
just I think I don't see why you
couldn't just start with this the same
theorem which is randomized decision
tree to information complexity notice I
don't see why there should be
oh just around the wise decision
treatment I don't see why there should
be any any difference between
information and random isn't for
composed watch it's like the difference
if I difference okay so the promise like
information complexity along some
branches might you might reveal a lot of
information and long other branches you
know
I mean the same things true about the
bits here no yeah yeah I don't know how
to do it yeah I don't know how to do it
yeah I think I don't see why you can't
just yeah but I think you're already
getting to Hulk what could be more
complicated about the proof for free
information like I mean yeah yes no
you're I mean yes so because randomness
is essential you'd have to like either
either either switch it to make a
distribution free or yeah you have to
work with the rig I think maybe this is
related to each other yeah yeah I'll
make the conjectured form that the
randomized complexity of you know the
randomize decision tree complexity maybe
I won't say it's exactly but like you
know close to the information complexity
of the composer I don't care about the
login or even if it's exactly right bits
um
whether somewhat technical but can you
instead of the other functions can be
drilled in the water a great question
nope don't know how to do that either at
least I don't think anybody yet and
that's how to do it it's because it's
basically so when we do this stuff where
we want to make sure that you know when
involved speaks and we want to make sure
that the that we can fix the bits and
that leaves us with these nice large
things that's heavily using the fact
that that the Y is so big that so much
information can be you know there's
density per tree storing partition thing
it could just basically flat out like
trick X up into every single possum
like all possible you know I mean that
that's not gonna happen probably but it
could do that and you'd still just be
fine in terms of why
you probably need a thing with something
yeah I think you need it there also but
I don't know where it's essential resign
any other question
[Applause]
yes moving back and forth